I'm a fighter because that's all I've
known how to be my name is Tonya Smith
and I'm a competitive historical center
we train in a system developed by a 14th
century master and practiced until the
16th century we've built a really
awesome community of women and we're all
doing it together
I train and teach in longsword it's my
primary weapon
I'm 5-2 and my long sword comes up to
shoulder level it's empowering and fun
you can use it to cut you could use it
to thrust you can get close and range
and grapple and really just kick ass
with classes were very very small in the
beginning it felt like I was the only
woman and being the token girl it was
something I was comfortable with at
first but as I got better and as I
started developing my goals as a fighter
I realized I wanted to have a community
of other women with shared philosophies
an event I planned was a women's
tournament one of the first of its kind
in the US
people will view of women's event as
lesser but I shouldn't have to beat
someone who stole my height or double my
weight to prove that I'm a good fencer
the standard should be beating the best
fighters
women make good fighters because they
want to be there they put their heart
and souls into it
you don't do this because you're forced
to be there you don't do this because
there's an expectation to be there they
do it because they're passionate about
it
police say the shots came from one or
more vehicles over 1200 shootings the
city so far this year
it's time for someone to step up and
fathom advisor
Inglewood is historically one of the
worst neighborhoods in the city of
Chicago and also in the entire United
States of America there have been
children murdered while sleeping in
their beds because bullets penetrated
the walls while they were sleeping
Inglewood is generally a place where no
one feels safe what brought me to the
corner of 75th and Stewart was a young
lady was murdered her name was Lucille
Barnes she was 34 and she was a mother
and she was just trying to break up a
fight and she was killed in a drive-by I
didn't know her but I was outraged and I
felt like at this point if mothers are
being murdered something has to be done
some people thought that it was too
dangerous to go and sit on a corner in a
place where someone had just been
murdered three days before we went out
we put on pink t-shirts and we went and
sat on the corner we got some hot dogs
and we fed people we talked to people
more importantly we gave out a lot of
hugs so we got together these moms who
have the time and who had the passion
for it and I felt that you know being
there and being a present and having
eyes on the street and eyes on the
children that it would interrupt and it
would prevent a lot of stuff that could
potentially happen while you're doing
that you're playing a game with a kid
that you may never get to play with we
want them to grow up together so that
when they're older they're not enemies
and they're not targets of one another
they're not shooting or killing each
other since we posted up on the corner
of 75th and Stewart there have been no
shootings on that block no shootings no
murders there hasn't even been as much
as a fistfight there's a sense of hope
that they didn't have before it all
because were mothers and you don't want
to underestimate the power of the mother
I'm skating with these women I feel on
fire
I love rollerskating so much that I
decided that I was going to bring it
back for everyone i'm michelle stylin
better known as estrogen and i'm the
founder of moxie roller skates there are
21 skaters on the moxie skate team
worldwide but some of them are pigeon
indeed Jimmy John's smelly and what Lex
anything that's experimental or outside
of what you've probably seen on roller
skates is what we do roller skating was
really really big until I was born and
then it really kind of dropped off when
rollerblades came in roller skate
innovation just stopped
roller derby was the next new sport to
come to the roller skating industry this
meets that they were selling the roller
derby skaters were made for speed the
skates that we're making now are made
for secure landings for high-flying
tricks you know a few years ago their
work let's gals doing backflips and on
their own wheels and now they're are and
I'm amazed at what my body can do I
really am we are chasing our dreams
we're chasing that feeling that
wonderful Flowbee feeling of being alive
and
you will get that from rollers skinny
it's this strange new feeling that's
refreshing
ah this Restless
our mariachi florida Toloache is
different than most deities were formed
in New York City
we're all women most people think of my
DHS being from Mexico as being men as
being macho and you know were pretty
much opposite of all those things I
started my musical career playing with
local all-male mariachi in Brooklyn
for me was really hard to communicate
with other male mariachis because of the
machismo
that's very vivid and the culture and in
the genre that's right yeah that's kind
of why I I wanted to start my own group
and that led for me to do a all-female
group because I didn't want to deal with
men and it's not so much that people say
you're not a mariachi but it's the fact
that they think that we cannot play
money at you because we're women and
we're wearing pens and we have curly
hair and and we don't look Mexican or we
don't have this look that they're
expecting
as a women mariachi we're technically
supposed to be wearing skirts and didn't
work for us it's one of the most
passionate music that I've ever heard is
just beautiful
it's very heartfelt and I think this one
makes my dancers so special my dream to
be able to perform and connect with
people through music I don't think I
could ask for more that's my name is
Leena Khalifa
I mean the owner and founder of
shea-porter the first self-defense to
deal for women in the Middle East
I teach mix between Taekwondo boxing and
pure self-defense techniques we also
empower women through seminars and
workshops like domestic violence sexual
harassment assault and also women
empowerment
I certain in 2004 because one of my
friends got abused by her father
uncovered I was really upset about their
situation because I have a background in
martial arts I decided to start giving
lessons for women in self-defense
domestic violence is a high percent in
Jordan in in violence for women we have
street harassment you don't see lots of
girls walking the street because of that
she fought a safe place for women to
come and talk about their issues because
all the other girls have been mostly the
same experience the physical training
and mental training both are really
important so we thought with talking to
the girls about their stories then we
moved to the training we have trained
and empowered more than 12,000 women
before any joint I was facing like a lot
of verbal harassment I felt so weak
because I couldn't do anything about it
since I joined verbal harassment is less
now because I'm more confident now so
when walking in street that shows like
that reflects to other people muskers
here after the training they feel that
they can stand up for themselves it's
about providing them with the
self-defense skills to defend their
rights and to have a voice in society